we're at Science Gallery in Trinity
College Dublin and we're at the elements
exhibition which is all about the
periodic table elements and all the
elements that make up our world so we
have lots of going on lots of
Interactive's but what we're going to
take a look at is the portraits of the
elements gallery
this is mercury everybody knows what
mercury looks like it's the only sort of
liquid metal at room temperature but we
just got a pool of it and that's just a
speaker we have under doing a real sort
of deep bass note yeah the other stuff
is sulfur so that if there's a leak that
will turn black it's kind of the canary
in the coalmine because if you have a
mercury spill that's very very bad
because it's super super toxic so we
have that in as a sort of warning
mechanism
got a piece of gold donated not
permanently obviously but on loan from
gold core and we thought we're getting
one ounce we got 10 ounces so as you
know gold is really expensive at the
moment it's skyrocket in price so that
little 10 ounce bar of gold it's
definitely worth over ten thousand euro
I haven't held that piece no and I don't
think they're probably going to let me
now that it's in the case and secured I
don't think they're going to let anybody
take it out
4-iron we have an amazing piece of art
that you can't see it's just below here
but it's by one of one of the Britain's
leading artists anthony gormley who's is
everybody knows from like large human
statues but this one is a piece of iron
which if you want to see you're going to
have to come and see the part of the
agreement as as is the piece of art you
can't photograph this we can't we can't
actually show you but it's it's a
beautiful piece of iron if you know iron
it's sort of erodes after a while and
get that lovely sort of colour to it so
I can only describe it so much you have
to see it yourself but it's a big ugly
piece that we're really really excited
to have and probably probably the most
valuable piece we have in the gallery
maybe ever have had
this is a late 19th century piece of
wallpaper done by William Morris and
it's he's arsenic to get the green color
arsenic has the amazing green color and
before it was known it to be really
toxic people would use it in a lot of
Dexter stuff we can't actually know if
he use arsenic in this one but in lots
of his wallpapers he used arsenic for
lots of the detailing you can see just
to get that lovely green color
for calcium we have a human bone
actually a human foot and I'm not often
creeped out by what we have in the
gallery but this is this is kind of a
bit interesting to me but I'm calcium is
in your bones that you need a lot of
calcium for your bones so it's one of
the elements that makes us up
this is a diamond ring so it looks just
like a diamond this is our piece for
carbon but it's not just any time to
ring because we could sort of feature
any time and this is a synthetic diamond
created in the lab out of the ashes from
someone's cremation so it's a mat in
Florida and there's a company that will
do this for you take your Croatian ashes
and make them into a diamond first time
I've ever even heard of it but it's a
it's beautiful again it's one of those
sort of really odd ways that we're sort
of projecting a meaning onto one of the
elements even if it's in its most pure
form so it looks like a beautiful
diamond until you realize that's that's
the remains of a person away and then it
takes on a kind of a different
significance
you're actually looking through a
silicon wafer disk this is the disk they
make to print chips on for your computer
so it's extremely fragile if you even
get like a fingerprint on that it's done
and this is silicon so it's really
really thin
really hard to make and this is where
the dress and those sort of spacesuit
looking things to hold just so they have
it exactly clean when they print on the
on the chip
these are cobalt blue glasses if you've
ever been if you're been walking by the
beach and you see some really blue
colored sea glass especially if it's
around an area that had sort of an
industrial revolution boom we might be
seeing cobalt glass because cobalt glass
was used as a dye you know before we had
artificial dyes you can make this very
easily now without cobalt but cobalt was
the diet they used
so inside that vacuum Bell is a little
cylinder which is exactly one kilogram
of platinum so it's probably the
interpretive material is probably the
most valuable thing we have in the
gallery probably in the region of 40,000
pounds plus but just that little piece
there is so precise there's a piece just
like it which is actually made of
platinum and iridium which is the
international standard for the kilogram
this is a replica but it's still an
amazingly viable and incredible piece
because it takes incredible precision to
get it to that exact measurement by
which all the kilograms are measured yes
it's a cylinder in the middle where all
the sort of white buffer things are
around it holding it in place
they don't just mail it to your career
we have to send somebody on plane get it
and you know hold the briefcase carried
onboard the plane not quite with this
sort of handcuff you know when bodyguard
kind of thing but it did have to be
under basic personal escort the whole
time
we are not demonstrating a neon light
even though it looks like a neon light
and it's called in the unlike many times
but this is an argon light since our
piece for argon and it reads this is not
a neon sign and because many people
think neon signs are all made of neon
but you can actually use argon xenon any
of the noble gases I don't know if you
can use radon but you probably wouldn't
want to anyway but you can you can see
we have different colors here but that's
just the way the tube is treated you can
also get different colors by mixing the
noble gases together
so this is a remnant of the radium craze
where people thought it was really good
and energizing if you ingested radium
now that's not true because it kills you
it's terrible for you it's a radioactive
element but what people would do here is
take this sort of container which the
the clay and the mold was made out of
radium in it and people would pour water
in and then every day the instructions
actually read fill jar every night use
hydrant or any good water drink freely
one thirsty and upon rising and retiring
average six or more glasses daily so
it's not just a new fad drink drink your
six or eight glass of water but this one
would have given you radioactive water
so very very bad for you to drink
but people actually did it because as
you can see the silent it's as you know
the raviga Torr and it you know we
vitalizes you and gives you energy so a
kind of a sick and weird remnant of our
misunderstanding of one of the elements
this is our piece for lead and it's a
it's a beautiful artistic piece this
artist has unwound a bullet and
structured it into this beautifully sort
of woven shape so it's kind of you know
make art not war kind of message that
that's what I take from it
so this piece is
a delicate piece made out of copper so
it's a piece for copper and as you can
see it's really really intricate and
it's woven I don't want to think about
how long it took to make
I'm standing I'm setting a bit away
because there's a sign that says
low-level radiation source please be
thirty thirty centimeters away because
this is a model of a nuclear reactor
that's actually made out of uranium
glass so it is a low-level radiation
source far below what has steamed a safe
standard I want to see if everybody's
running away now but it's not actually
glowing green like that that's lit that
way but it's a beautiful sculpture